У 2015 році доброволець батальйону "Донбас" Володимир Дериведмідь вирішив дати бій русифікації.
Залишився у Бахмуті - і відкрив українську книгарню.
Стенди зробив на пенсію, а книжки намагається продавати за ціною видавництв.
Магазин назвав на честь побратима Антона Цедіка, який мав позивний Еней
і був великим книголюбом - навіть в Іловайськ поїхав із книжкою у наплічнику.
Це мені так розірвало душу, що я подумав, що потрібно залишитися тут
і спробувати залишити таку пам'ять, яка не раз на рік відмічається,
а яка буде діяти постійно - щодня.
І я вирішив: якщо це пам'ять про Антона, який загинув із книгою, то це має бути книгарня.
Тим паче я знав, що на Донбасі у нас книгарень немає.
Я зрозумів, що боротьба повинна бути насамперед за мізки і душу.
Володимир Дериведмідь - танкіст, майор запасу.
Народився на Дніпропетровщині, служив у Білорусі, Німеччині та Афганістані.
До війни 15 років жив у Києві, а до цього стільки ж - у Бахмуті, який тоді називався Артемівськ.
Каже, "українізувався" саме на Донбасі - коли на початку 90-х донька потрапила
у першу в місті україномовну групу в дитячому садочку.
Через півтора тижня я її забираю, а моя дитина мені каже:
"Добрий вечір, тато!" Боже, в мене сльози потекли.
Я 27 років всім розповідав, що я інтернаціоналіст.
І тут, в Артемівську, у 1993 році я зрозумів, що я не інтернаціоналіст, а українець.
І це мені підказала моя маленька донька.
Куми, сусіди, друзі дивилися на мене із посмішкою: "Ты что, Володя, по приколу?"
Я кажу: "Я українець, я зрозумів, що мені це дорого, мені це потрібно".
А до 14 років, до Суворівського училища, я жив у селі - там був хоч і суржик,
але українська мова. І мій батько завжди співав "Дивлюсь я на небо і думку гадаю".
Нині дім книги "Еней" - одне з небагатьох місць у Бахмуті, де можна поспілкуватись українською.
У магазині діти декламують вірші та отримують за це подарунки.
Навертає на українську також дорослих.
Переселенка з Донецька Оксана Судак - вже два роки постійна відвідувачка книгарні.
У 2018 році я познайомилася із власником цієї книгарні, з Володимиром Дмитровичем,
і зрозуміла, що це дуже важливо.
Тоді на магазині висів банер із написом: "Дім книги на Донбасі важливіший за 20 танків".
Він тоді запропонував мені перейти на українську мову.
Сказав, що буде зі мною спілкуватися перший час.
І ми одне одного виправляли - з російських слів на українські.
Я вважаю, зараз нам надто важливо зберігати свою українську сутність,
бо війна іде якраз на знищення української ідентифікації,
знищення такого поняття як українець.
Утім, незабаром сімдесятитисячний Бахмут може залишитися без єдиної української книгарні.
69-річний Володимир Дериведмідь каже, що має повертатися до Києва - через сімейні обставини.
Два місяці тому навіть оголосив про закриття магазину.
Проте відвідувачі книгарні переконали спробувати знайти наступника.
Цей магазин я готовий залишити, але не просто людині, яка продаватиме якусь гастрономію,
ковбасу чи горілку, а людині, яка любить читати,
яка любить українську мову. У мене є кадрова проблема.
Знайти таку людину - той ще квест.
Адже торгівля книжками, тим паче українськими, у Бахмуті радше активізм, ніж бізнес.
Підтримки від влади очікувати годі.
А за проукраїнську позицію можна постраждати.
За шість років тут було порізано вісім портретів загиблих.
А біля Артема завжди квіти розкидали.
Поліція жодних заходів не вживає, справи не порушує,
кажуть: матеріальні збитки малі…
Крім книгарні "Еней" осередки української культури у Бахмуті можна перелічити на пальцях.
Українство тут і сім років після звільнення від сепаратистів - у підпіллі.
Інколи - у буквальному розумінні.
У тому ж підвалі, де розташований єдиний у місті храм ПЦУ,
волонтери плетуть маскувальні сітки для військових,
що тримають позиції на підступах до міста.
Ми плетемо з початку війни. Потреба зараз дуже велика.
Держава щось дає, але чогось не вистачає.
І якщо оці наші сітки збережуть хоч одне життя наших воїнів, цим варто займатися.
Коли почалася війна, я зрозуміла: чому ми на своїй території повинні себе захищати?
Мабуть, на нас же хтось напав? А хто? Росія.
- А чому Ви своє обличчя не хочете показувати?
- Чувство осторожности и самосохранения.
Тим часом засновник єдиної у Бахмуті української книгарні Володимир Дериведмідь
не втрачає надії знайти людину, яка продовжить його справу,
і врятує магазин від закриття.
А згодом сподівається залучитися підтримкою громадськості та здійснити давню мрію
- відкрити у місті будинок книги всеукраїнського значення.
Нам потрібно отримати перемогу в культурі перш за все.
А щоб отримати перемогу в культурі, потрібно замість одного танка
побудувати найсучаснішу, найкращу книгарню в Бахмуті.